all right I think we'll get
bugging your website with fiddler and
chrome developer tools a little bit
about myself so I've been a web
developer since 1995 I work full-time
for an e-commerce site and then I do
conference speaking and Pluralsight
videos as well got my email my Twitter
and my blog information up there so if
you need to get a hold of me at some
point you can reach out via those so
we'll dive right in we're going to talk
about HTTP today so HTTP is the
hypertext Transfer Protocol I gave you
the two lengths to the two current
versions HTTP 1.1 HTTP 2 as we're going
to focus on when we're looking at our
web troubleshooting it's a request and
response paradigm I put an asterisk
after that there is a feature in HTTP 2
called server push that would be the
first time that servers are actually
initiating connections to clients but in
general the client will make a request
the server is going to respond each one
of the requests and responses is going
to have a header with just meta
information about that request or
response along with the body that has
the actual content so I do a lot of
mentoring for new web developers and so
I like to show them what an actual get
request looks like in case they haven't
seen one on the wire I think it helps
answer questions they might have about
you know do I know client resolution do
I know how many colors the client
supports no I mean this is all that gets
sent up from a client to a server as far
as when the server is going to make
decisions this is all that's going to
see so typical requests will have a get
so I'm just i want to retrieve something
from this URL in this case decline is
specifying it wants to use HTTP 1.1
these are the other headers that get
transmitted along and we'll look at
these as we go but except language is
just saying this is the language I have
my browser configured for so if you
happen to have a multilingual website
that's how the server knows what
language to respond with will see the
user agents as we go through some stuff
everybody lines right they have all
sorts of things in there that they
really aren't but just to advertise
usually there's one thing you can key
into to tell you what that specific
browser is I don't personally do a lot
of browsers and
on servers but if you need to take
advantage of that for some reason we'll
talk about encoding later and we can get
into performance that just says the
client supports compression and the host
header lets the server know which of the
particular sites it needs to route to so
if you're using iis like I am the host
header lets me use a single IP address
for all the sites that I have it
actually sees that host header in the
request and it knows which one of the is
sites it needs to serve ok so that's
what a basic get request looks like if
we look at a typical response we'll see
the server did indeed say it'll use HTTP
1.1 200 just means that everything went
ok there's a whole list of all the
different status codes it has the date
on here when the response was I see
we're being kind to hackers here right
we're telling them exactly what we run
usually it's nice to give them a version
number - it can save some time but it's
also saying how long it wants you to
keep it in the cache so we'll talk about
expirations later and again just some
more headers talking about what's here
how big the content is a blank line and
then the actual body for that content so
that's the typical request response
paradigm we're going to look at in the
tools that we're using by the way if you
have any questions feel free to
interrupt we do have a microphone so we
get down the recordings just raise your
hand and we'll go as we go so we'll
start with what is fiddler so Fiddler's
a tracing tool that was built
specifically for HTTP so Erik Lawrence
was working at Microsoft I think he was
on the clipart team and people would
call in customers would call and say we
ordered clipart we can't download it and
he was listening to his own customer
service people try to help them and
there were no good tools around to try
to help troubleshoot what's going wrong
why doesn't this download so back then
Microsoft had met Mon which is similar
to Wireshark and also you use any of
those but it does work it's a packet
tracing tool it's not very fun to look
through that tool and try to reassemble
the full get and the full response so
you said I want to make a super simple
tor tool specifically for HTTP that
makes it as easy as what you just saw
here's the full request
here's
full response so he worked on that
part-time when he was at Microsoft he
decided that he wanted to work on it
full-time so he asked Microsoft will you
allow me to work on this full-time and
they said no so he started looking for
some other partners that might be
interested and he actually I was
acquired by telluric in 2012 so he
became a full-time employee with
telluric and I think he worked there
three years and now he's moved on to
work at chrome so telluric now owns
fiddler they promise to keep it free and
they've been doing a lot of innovations
lately so the people who currently own
it you can download it from fiddler to
calm it is free it's written in c-sharp
so we'll talk about some of the dotnet
stuff potentially as we get into it but
I think it's cool that he said he didn't
know HTTP he didn't know dotnet he
didn't know c-sharp and he went and
learned all that and wrote fiddler which
is pretty impressive on the side it's
what he did on weekends and stuff over
whatever it was 10 to 13 years from when
he started so I've used it for a long
time it's a really great tool so we'll
just show the basics of how we're going
to run this so I'm going to startup
fiddler we go into Chrome and just pick
the conference website I have some of
the cash I'm just going to remove all
I'm going to hit ctrl f5 and chrome to
force it to refresh and then we'll just
watch all the requests so the other
thing I like to show web developers and
I occasionally will show this to my
marketing group too just to show them
that it's not a single request between
the client and the server to get a web
page there's a lot of requests I'll show
you HTTP archive if we have time later
the average web page today is about 105
requests I think it's up to two and a
half Meg the average web page which like
I said I've been doing this for a long
time that kind of freaks me out that's
as big as the doom program needs to be
so if you ever used to play Doom on a PC
your installer average web page is
actually bigger than that now just to
give you an idea of context and you'll
see it grow over the years
but inside a fiddler what we'll look at
is on the left hand side these are all
the requests that were made so it made
the HTM request and I'm going to go on
the right-hand side here I just like
looking at the raw requests popping into
notepads you can see it better but that
looks like what we looked at before so
that's just my client asking for the
homepage on that particular host I'm
going to take this off you'll see this
little animal shows up this gold bar
here that says that the response body is
encoded it's actually compressed which
is a good thing so I'm going to take
that off and we'll look at the raw
response and you'll see the same thing
it's got all the same headers and then
the actual body for the HTML that came
down okay and then all of these
additional requests are all the
JavaScript the CSS all the images that
make up that page are all downloaded and
we can look at those individually and
we'll look at that as we go through this
talk again you can get it from fiddler
to there's a lot of different things out
here they actually have some pretty good
documentation they have some videos out
here as well they've got different areas
that you might want to use fiddler for
and they walk through that they've now
also got so the normal download was for
dotnet they also have a beta that runs
on mono and they just put out a beta for
OSX so we'll talk about a little bit
later at how you can troubleshoot
devices other than Windows but just be
aware that those are out there as well
so you can come and download down so how
does fiddler work so I talked about
Wireshark and net Mon those kind of
network monitoring programs are sitting
on a wireless adapter or your network
adapter and they're just intercepting
all the calls that go through that
particular adapter that's not how
Fiddler's work fiddler is actually set
up as it's a separate application and
you're going to set it up via a proxy so
if you're familiar most companies have a
proxy server that you all your computers
will connect you to get out to the
Internet the idea with this is whatever
client I'm using I need to configure its
proxy to point at where fiddler is that
way all that stuff will get sent through
fiddler and can get traced okay so what
fiddler does by default as soon as I
open fiddler it's going to look for all
the open browser instances that I have
and it will actually go in and change
their configuration to route through
fiddler so I'm going to show you what
that looks
becomes important later when we talk
about tracing different clients and
stuff that you understand that it goes
through a proxy so I've got Sadler
running right here if I open Chrome we
go look at the settings put onto
advanced we've got change proxy settings
if I come in here it's got use a proxy
server have you ever seen the shirt
there's no place like one 27.0 that 0.1
yeah
no place like home this points to your
own machine so this points to localhost
so what it's done is it says fiddler is
running on port 80 8 8 8 on this machine
so I'm going to set my proxy to point at
this machine in that port now everything
I'm doing in that browser is being
routed through fiddler ok so that's how
fiddler is actually getting set up and
that's how it sees all that traffic kind
of freaked out our security group at
first they didn't they weren't happy to
have net Mon or Wireshark people running
and especially when we're all on
switchers before because you could watch
everybody else's network traffic that's
not a good thing but with fiddler you
have to specifically route your proxy to
go through fiddler to be able to see
anything so you don't have that risk
that you're going to be looking at
things from other people's machines ok
and what as we go through the talk I'm
going to focus so I support an
e-commerce site I have a lot of
different clients I have to worry about
a lot of different devices that have
problems I tend to use fiddler first
because it gives me consistency so if
it's something I can do in fiddler I'm
going to do it in fiddler there's a lot
of things that I can't do in fiddler
that I'm going to fall back and that's
what I'll show you in chrome developer
tool so it doesn't mean that's not in
chrome developer tools it's just if I
can do it in fiddler then it's
consistent for me across all these
different devices this easier for me to
troubleshoot that way ok talk about
chrome developer tools I can hit f12
when I'm in Chrome to get into developer
tools or you can use the windows or mac
keyboard sequences when it comes to
developer tools there are flags you can
set so you can actually go to Chrome
flags and if you scroll down there'll be
a spot I can check that says I want to
use experimental developer tool things
none of the things I'm going to show you
in this talk
penned on that if you happen to run into
something where you see that's a cool
feature they may tell you to go there
and enable it because it's not enabled
by default for everybody but like said
none of the things I'm going to show you
are going to do that you could also get
canary so canary is meant for developers
and early adopters that want to see new
features that are potentially going to
make it into Chrome itself you can
download canary and you can run it side
by side again I'm not going to show you
anything in canary here everything I'm
going to show you is something that
works in shipping Chrome and I want to
do that because I have to troubleshoot
on other people's machines I want to be
able to use techniques that I know are
going to be available say of Chrome ok
but if you see things you can use one of
those so I'm going to try to focus on
different areas for the talk I'm going
to start with your site is failing and
you don't know why and break it down
into some different categories show some
simple examples from each one and how
these tools can help you troubleshoot
problems that you're having so the very
first one is somebody will come to me
and say their sites not working the
first thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to open fiddler and I'm going to check
all of the response status codes that
come back because that is very often
where I start realizing where their
problem is type a web page I can pull it
up in the browser just going to clear by
the way I'm just going to say remove all
to say less in here so I'm going to pull
up this particular page right away I see
it's not what I expect so this is
bootstrap I expected the top to have a
carousel that showed me some of the
different cities it's a fictitious
travel site and I can tell right away
that something's not working with this
like I said the first thing I'll do when
somebody says stuff doesn't work I want
to make sure that all of the files and
stuff they need are being pulled down
correctly so in this case I can look
through here's the request for the
actual page and right away nicely
highlighted in red if it were only this
simple all the time right that's my
problem the CSS stylesheet that is
controlling a lot of that look and feel
for that page isn't correct right I can
see that that file is not being
downloaded it's not very typical on your
own machine but how many times do you go
to somebody
else's and they said well it all worked
on my machine doesn't work when I got to
stage and so I'll start asking did he
deploy this did you move somebody
couldn't get their video to play did you
deploy everything yep go do this boom
the video file wasn't deployed where
it's supposed to be you get a 404 star
easy to fix that way so now that I see
this I'm going to show you this in
Chrome as well but I know that that's
probably what the problem is so here
again I'm going to hit f12 they have a
network tab here as well slide it up
this two hair here so if I go control f5
hit this request again and then if I
scroll up in here and see the same thing
that style sheet for whatever reason
that's not being pulled down like it
should be nice thing I can do in Chrome
if I want to I can come into here it
turns out that I know that that's not
the right style sheet name so somebody
mistyped it shouldn't be site one should
be just site could be that I deployed it
wrong could be the server's not working
so nice thing is I can come right here
and change it hit enter and I can see
immediately that now I get the
experience I wanted so I haven't had to
go back into the development environment
I can do a lot of stuff in the client
make adjustments see did that fix it or
not fix it
I can go then to the sources tab if I
want and see if I can see my list here
there's a way in here I can tell it
shows me that that's been modified on
the client and usually on here I'll see
my CSS file and then I can actually just
right-click and save it another thing I
can do I'm not going to show in here
there's a feature called workspaces so
you can actually set up a workspace in
Chrome to point to the folder so on my
own development machine I can actually
point to where the source code is so I
could make changes on the fly and the
CSS like that I can say save and I can
actually push it directly to the folder
with that CSS file sits now I do sass
and stuff in production and I do
bundling and minification so that
doesn't work out well for the way that I
do development but if you want to just
be aware that you can make changes with
them browser and actually push it via
workspaces okay
so again if I now know that that's the
problem I can come back in here I can
change this save it we go execute that
again now that change is going to be
permanent because it's not just in
developer tools and then everything
works like I would expect and I'm happy
AC be surprised how often it is
especially with people using CD ends and
third-party components and stuff it's
just a missing file or something not
deployed right that's a really quick way
to test and see that that's the problem
next one we'll talk about is JavaScript
errors so go the JavaScript file let's
pull this one up and what I expect for
this one is I've got an image on it and
I want to be able to click the image and
have it do a modal dialog box that shows
me like a zoomed in picture from this so
if I can click on this I can see I'm
using bootstrap I get the mobile to
pop-up but it doesn't have the picture
embedded or anything like I would expect
this is going to be a good case to use
developer tools for and so I'm going to
use Chrome developer tools and try to
troubleshoot this I could just try to
step through line by line until I
finally get to where I think the problem
is it's a lot easier in chrome I can
just actually set here's my on click
where I know the code is here that I
want it to run I can actually just type
the bugger and if I save that now what's
going to happen is when I go re execute
this when I get to the case where this
actually fires and get my thing to come
up here
why are you not behaving when I now shut
it down I'm just going to control f5
make sure I have the recent copy hit f12
now if I scroll down here I should be
able to click this and you'll see it
immediately paused in the debugger so it
hit my debugger statement and it's now
sitting directly where I am on that on
click so just saved me time to get to
where I was so now I'm going to hit f11
and start going into that file the first
thing you'll notice is I do minification
and bundling and stuff so that's all
minified all the white space is gone
that's not very entertaining when you're
trying to do client-side troubleshooting
so if you know there's this pretty print
on the bottom so I can actually just say
I want that to be unmet off' i'd if
that's a word we'll use that as a word
today so now it's unmet off' I'd it's
not back to the original source you can
see it's got things like our that isn't
what I named things that's just how some
of the minification occurred you can
look at source maps and other things to
try to get you back to the original
source but now I can actually start
stepping through here on the client next
thing you notice I'm going into jQuery
so I'm using jQuery for this I'm using
it in bootstrap not very often when I'm
troubleshooting is they're actually
going to be a problem in the jQuery
library in fact I've used it for years
I've never personally run into a library
problem so I don't really want to
troubleshoot in jQuery I can simply
right-click and say black box this
script when I do that what it's saying
is it's now going to save that in my
configuration every time I do
client-side debugging and it's about to
go to jQuery it's going to skip over all
of the jQuery code so I don't have to
spend time wasted looking to the jQuery
stuff so I'm going to come out of this
another thing you'll notice it's giving
me variable details so instead of having
to hover like I do in visual studio to
be able to see what some of the variable
contents are it's actually displaying it
to the side so there's actually features
it's on by default but if you didn't
like it you can turn it off display
variable values in line while debugging
that's what's giving me the feature
it's showing me as I'm stepping here
each line as you'll see as I go to the
next one it's showing me all the values
next to it that's where that feature
comes from so as I'm looking at
troubleshooting this I won't spend a lot
of time on this it turns out that I'm
using children and if I look at my
markup it's not a direct descendant
child I'm trying to find some content
that's further down so I'm trying to
find the title and the body of this I've
got this modal I want to get down into
these things and start playing with that
in the dom children isn't actually what
I should be using so when I looked at
the jQuery documentation it turns out to
be fun find instead of children so I can
fix that another thing that I'd like to
do on the server side I can actually set
something I can spend a lot of time on
this I just want to tell you that it's
there so I can do things like console
assert or I can do traces or warning or
debug all of those things are going to
get put out into the console for the
developer tools so in this case if I
were concerned I want to make sure that
when I do the children I get back
something that's at least length greater
than zero I can just say I want to
assert that if I save that and run that
again and I'll actually go click on this
again I'm paused in the debugger again
so now if I step in here let these a
pretty print if I open up the account so
I can hit escape and the console will
open here so it should show me must has
already tried right there there's my
assertion so I can put all of these
things in my JavaScript to tell me these
are things that are happening on the
client and there's a ton of things and
chrome and all the other developer tools
are pretty well standardized on what's
in the console so you just go out here
and search for the console reference
under chrome in this case but it shows
you all the things you can do with
assertions you can serialize objects
into the console so you can see all of
their contents do tracing to stack
traces etc so those are all things I can
add in them
javascript and when it comes to the
minification the pretty print is handy
but I don't like to do that if I have a
lot of different JavaScript files that's
where fiddler can help actually has a
feature called
make JavaScript pretty if I do that and
click in here because Fiddler's a proxy
between my client my server its
intercepting all of the requests it can
actually make modifications so it's
going to see all the minified javascript
files come back from the server and
actually unmess IM there and send them
down to the client so that i don't have
to look through and keep hitting
prettyprint
since i hit the skin now if i hit f12
and i want to do troubleshooting i can
look under the sources and close this i
can look at all the things that say
their minified here you can see actually
now our unman aside and i can do all my
troubleshooting the way that i want to
so if you do a lot of this and you don't
want to have to hit pretty print just be
aware that you can come in here and
change it and then fiddler notifies you
which files have actually modified by
doing some color coding to it to see
have an idea next thing we'll talk about
is style issues so we get a lot of CSS
styles we have to apply from third-party
and other people and of course when they
have their ads and wherever they want to
put in everything works perfect right I
mean it all lays out right everything's
ok I put it into our e-commerce site
things don't like work the way that they
should so I want to be able to
troubleshoot issues that I have with
those styles so again we'll do this in
Chrome developer tools so I've got my
page shut this
know what I can do is I look at this and
for whatever reason I didn't expect this
to be the color green so the fast way to
get to dev tools and see exactly where
this is I can just right click and say I
need to inspect that particular element
now it's going to bring down below it'll
bring me to the Styles tab so here I can
see all of the CSS style rules that were
applied to that particular element and
then I can make modifications to see if
I want to change anything so for
instance I can see the reason I'm
getting green here it's coming from
custom CSS that's the file that that
rule came from if I want to I can simply
say I want to turn that off and see what
other style would apply it turns out I
didn't have any other styles in here so
it fell back to what the browser default
would be but if you see it slashes out
things that other rules take over so
it's very handy to come in here and say
yeah I know I've got all these style
rules and this one should be working but
it struck out because some other rule
ended up winning and then you can
troubleshoot why is that rule if you've
ever looked at like CSS I hate this word
specificity actually senator agency very
specific rules about how things get
applied so if it turns out at least I
can see that it was struck out and I can
go figure out and try to understand
which rule is applying here and why the
other thing I can do is I can come here
and actually change the color so they
have a nice color picker I can just type
this by hand if I want to I'm not a
designer so I'll do orange but I can
make those changes on on the client on
the fly they also have where they have
autocomplete so if I want to make a new
rule here I can just start typing like
maybe this is really foreground color or
back color that I want to change you can
see it's giving me autocomplete or
type-ahead so it's got nice features for
that some of the other things that I can
do in here is that if I have some
particular style rules on hover so let's
say I want to go and look at this
element again I happen to have a hover
rule I can actually come here and say I
want to force that into a hover State so
now when I do that I expected it to be
another color
I've got another style in there for
hover I think I'll do this one
control of funds see now I'm targeting
this if we go back here you can see well
in this case it's applying sorry for the
resolution here this is some of the
strikeout stuff I was showing what just
shows this rule now overrode the other
one because it's targeting a specific ID
if you don't want to look at the style
we see all those strikeouts you can
actually go to compute it and it's just
going to show you all the actual
properties and all of their values so if
you don't really care which rule is it
that made it this way but you want to
see what it is or you want to edit it
you can do that directly here like I
said we use this a lot that's how we
find style problems because otherwise
it's just not very entertaining this is
a good way for me to client-side
troubleshoot that stuff and then they
also have the box model I can play with
but that's the core thing that we'll do
is under the Styles tab just try to
troubleshoot what's wrong with our
styles next one is performance concerns
so I have a lot of people I do a lot of
web performance work that will say my
sites not working I want to understand
why so we'll talk about ways to
troubleshoot that so open up fiddler
here we'll go back to the conference
website and clear all of them and just
do a refresh so I'm just doing a control
f5 which is forcing all those requests
to get remade so if anything was cast on
the client I want to see all the
requests that go on an initial so
there's a lot of things I can do in here
because I've done a lot of web
performance work I kind of know what to
look for so I'm just going to tip you
off to things that they should be doing
or ways to investigate where the problem
usually is so we'll start here the first
thing I look at is the HTML that comes
back I do notice that it's compressed so
if you don't use HTTP compression on
your web servers you should we turned it
out on our e-commerce site like 10 years
ago and I cut our bandwidth usage in
half so it's free it's built into all
the web servers all of your static files
you should do compression we use it for
all of our dynamic files as well so it's
good that they're doing that if I look
at their CSS file I'm going to take that
off and just look
it looks like they have it minified
which is good that's the best practice
we'll do the same for the JavaScript
take this off see that's minified as
well so they're doing minification you
notice though they're not doing any
bundling so they actually have five or
six separate JavaScript files so we
minified and we take all of our
javascript files and put them into a
single bundle with a version number
every time we do a build and that also
cut our home page time in half it just
makes that big of a difference because
when you looked at fiddler all these
requests have to go back and forth
between your client your server
potentially over a slow Network the less
things that you have to transmit where
you're doing that back and forth over
that latency the better so that's
something they should do next thing I'll
typically do is I'll sort by the body
just to see what the biggest files are
so we see that Scott Allen is being a
hog at 285 K so the first thing I
noticed by looking at this that's pretty
big for an image and it's a PNG which
strikes me as odd I mean photos should
really be JPEGs not PNG s so I can
quickly go out first thing I'll do is
I'll save off this image so I can
actually just say I want to save the
response body so I'm going to just save
that on the desktop I happen to use
Paint Shop Pro there's a lot of other
tools to do editing of images but I'm
going to go open up that file and just
by doing a saving it as a JPEG one of
the things they have in here they have
an optimizer so I actually do a side by
side and JPEG you can do compression and
trade-off quality for size so I'm just
going to start changing the quality see
if I put it at 90 it's going to tell me
I'll get down to 18k but you'll see now
it's got some artifacts in there so I'd
probably back off to like 75 yeah he
still looks decent there she'll do that
I'm going to save this to the desktop as
well then if we go do a quick compare
that's 24k instead of 288 some K so it's
just a tip off when you
see things like this quickly you can see
it's pngs when it really shouldn't be
they're really big and then the other
thing I noticed is I'm not in this list
all these other guys I'm not in there so
anyways but that's some of the quick
performance things that you can do in
fiddler if you know some of the
performance rules you can just look
through for specific things that you
know the other one that's slightly off
the screen here is caching so by default
somebody comes to my home page gets my
HTML I listed out all my CSS JavaScript
and images it downloads them all they
close the browser they come back
tomorrow what I'd like to do is if I
haven't changed any of those things I'd
like to have it served right off their
own machine I mean it's sitting in their
browser cache on their machine it's
never going to get faster than to use
that if you don't set expirations on
your content to tell it how long this
stuff is considered fresh your browser
has to guess and a lot of times it's
going to go back to the server and say I
have a file I got yesterday hasn't been
changed since then and since you have a
hundred and four requests or whatever on
a typical web page that's a hundred and
four trips back to your web server to
find out that nothing actually changed
so we set expiration for all of our
images for 30 days our JavaScript and
CSS we do for a year because we have
version numbers built into them that way
when you come and revisit tomorrow you
don't have to download any of those
images again okay if it turns out I
really have to change the logo I'll just
change the name to logo one jpg instead
of logo and that'll everybody won't have
that in their browser and they'll come
back and get it so the other thing I
notice on here they're not using a lot
of caching for things like all those
pictures for the speakers so if I come
back later it's up to my browser I don't
want to leave it up to the browser to
decide if it's going to go ask again I
want to set expirations and that's
something else that's missing on there
so that's some quick performance things
the other things you can do in chrome
dev tools they have an audit stab so if
you're not real familiar with the
performance rules and you just want to
get a rough assessment of your page you
can actually come in here and say I want
to run a web page performance audit and
it's actually going to spit out
things that it thinks that you should do
so if I look at some of these it's just
going to say I've got all these images I
don't have dimensions specified for
tells me I can minimize my cookie size
things like that usually this comes up
with more specific so here there sorry
there at the bottom remove some of the
unused CSS rules and look at your images
and tell you if you could make them
smaller by doing some compression on
them so that's pretty decent I'm going
to cheat one time in my talk and go
outside of dev tools and the other one
because they used to have this in dev
tools when I took it out chrome has a
PageSpeed insights I can actually you'll
punch in a URL and it will do a mobile
and desktop performance analysis for me
and break down things that I should SiC
so it's similar to the auditing it just
has more capabilities than what's built
in the dev tool so again I can come out
here and see here a bunch of different
images that they basically took every
image compressed it and said I think you
could do better on your size by doing
more compression of these images
okay so again just a nice tool to be
able to get a sense for how your
performance is mixed content warning so
if you haven't have a site that's not
completely HTTP somebody gives you some
of their content or even if you are they
give you content that's not using HTTPS
and you get that mixed content warning
that's annoying it's very easy to find
that in Chrome so
so you pull up the page I'll hit up 12
I'm going to re-request this I'm going
to go to the Security tab and hit
control of size and what I'll say is
they've broken it into a specific area
where it says you have a particular
resource on here that's not being
requested correctly and I can see its
Lunden jpg on mixed content dot HTM and
see right here it's referencing it with
HTTP colon even though it's a HTTP page
you shouldn't do that I've used what's
called protocol s links for a while so
they actually go back to this page on
the server here and instead of
referencing that like this I can leave
off the protocol that'll actually say I
don't care if you're HTTPS or HTTP match
the protocol the page is using to make
this request so now when it's on an
HTTPS page like this one so I hit ctrl
f5 again it's going to request and now
everything's green everybody's happy and
I don't get that mixed content warning
like I would get at ie
it's not easy to find these with other
things it's nice that's easy to do if
you're in Chrome developer tools
also the next thing is always compare a
success and failure so we have a lot of
cases where something doesn't work so we
we own a lot of different food companies
so you could go and find where to buy
our pizza that would use html5
geolocation on the client and figure out
your lat long and then we plot out all
of this in places you could buy our
product and works fine somebody did
something of course and suddenly it
didn't work anymore but only on iPhones
didn't work so we did some tracing with
our various tools and we couldn't spot
it so what I did is I actually pulled up
I pulled up a fiddler trace of one that
worked so I knew that edge worked we'll
see things have been here at all one
see here's the latch and I just looked
at this and said okay this is one that
works I don't know why this one works
and then I pulled up one that didn't
work so I pull up a trace of an iPhone
and the thing I noticed was the
precision from the iPhone was much more
decimal points than the one on the other
one I mean I had looked at it for days
and I couldn't figure out what was
different when I did the trace of the
two of them and then can look at the
requests and Fiddler's side-by-side it
became immediately obvious that this had
a lot more precision turns out somebody
swapped out our back-end to a different
tool and that one could not handle that
many decimals of precision it was dying
so so the point of it is if you're
running into things you can't
troubleshoot take a working and a
nonworking and then eyeball the two of
them but side-by-side because then you
can often see what's different about the
two and be able to figure it out now
who's doing that often have pages where
you think it's going to look one way but
somebody is changing it so I've got an
example of a page
I've got a page you know it looks great
just got a little time delay on it so
I'm sitting here maybe reviewing this
page and said yeah that's exactly what I
expect and then suddenly suddenly there
we go and I think why does that happen
who just made a modification to this and
trying to figure out through all of our
JavaScript and third-party stuff we use
who did that is not very entertaining
what I can do is I can say inspect now
I'm on that particular area I can right
click and say please break on sub-3
modifications or attribute modifications
so now if I run this again what it's
going to do it's going to take it's got
a timer in there to sleep but after
about 10 or 15 seconds it's going to
find as soon as that thing gets modified
it's going to pop me into the debugger
on the client and it's going to give me
a stack trace to who actually made that
call so there I got the pop and then
here there's the code right there so now
I can go look and say I don't know why
somebody did this but they're
specifically changing the class on this
attribute and they're changing the HTML
so again when you have a lot of moving
parts it's hard to see who's actually
making changes to your Dom you can
actually just say that break on a little
target and pause directly on who made
that modification ok next one is I flip
those around sorry who requested that so
there's a lot of times where somebody
will come to us and say you know we did
a fiddler trace or you know there's this
javascript file in there we didn't
expect or I'm going to show you an
example of a font how do you figure out
who actually made that request so go
back to fiddler I'm going to clear this
out
so they made a request and let's say in
this scenario we're using web fonts we
have corporate stance and what the fonts
supposed to be they're not using the
corporate fonts and now we're getting an
extra download we don't want who's doing
that why is that getting pulled in so
fiddler does have a searching tool I can
find sessions the important thing is
this I used the tool forever and I never
knew what that setting was and I was
searching if you have compressed content
the search wasn't actually looking into
any of the compressed content so I would
never get matches in the tool and I
thought to find just sucked and I didn't
know why if you check this anything
that's actually compressed now we'll get
uncompressed and you should be doing
compression so you just set that if you
do find sessions now it shows me
bootstrap is the one that's pulling that
in so now I can go in as a bootstrap
file so it just helps me figure out
again when you have a lot of third-party
libraries and such who's pulling in this
extra file or why is this getting used
it's a quick way for me to troubleshoot
and see where that is there's another
place it's in developer tools I will
admit that this is a little flaky and
doesn't always work so I'm just going to
show you not working if you believe me
you can actually see there's an
initiator column right here
that tells you who is it that drove this
request so in this initiator that should
point directly at who requested that
file so if I go to this halflings right
here it says it's bootstrap line 153 but
if I click that it's actually jQuery
file which isn't correct I want you to
know if you're stuck sometimes initiator
is correct
and sometimes it saves you a ton of time
just be aware that it's not always right
okay it's a little flaky but that's a
good way to pinpoint who's making
requests for that particular file the
next branch of things we're going to
look at is what if so what if I did
certain things how would things be
different so the first thing is what if
the request was different so because
fiddler is acting as a proxy it can
actually intercept all of the requests
between the client and server and allow
me to make modifications
so I've got a simple page here it's
supposed to do validation so if I hit
one it says hey that's great
if I hit zero I have client-side
JavaScript saying that you know that's
not valid everybody knows client-side
JavaScript does nothing for real
security right I mean it's just a user
interface or interaction thing so what I
want to see is I want to see that the
server person do it correctly will this
work if Java scripts not enabled I'm a
real fast way to do that there's a
composer tab
I think somebody showed me that was
using this in an earlier demo today too
if I drag this guy over and drop it it's
going to have the request that I made so
let me pull the other one because I want
to post so here's my successful post
when I posted when I was posting the
value one in the textbox I'm going to
just change that so literally I can
change anything in the request and send
it to the server this isn't always easy
to do it's super easy and fiddler so
I'll say go re-execute that then I can
look at that I'll go look at what its
response was and you can see the value 0
it shouldn't be doing that right it
shouldn't have gone to the server and
allow that to occur so the people on the
server are not doing validation the way
they're supposed to and that was a fast
way to find it another thing I can do
with this if I go back to composer like
said I can change literally anything in
here so if I drag this request over I
can play with what if the client doesn't
support compression you know is my
server responding correctly so I can
execute that go back to the response
you'll see there's no gold bar here it's
not compressed anymore so we use this a
lot for doing various security testing
and stuff faster than writing a client
that can make up headers and things I
can just drag those requests over and
change them as I want okay what if
something was blocked so if we go into
will do this one in fiddler you can
actually go into they have a bunch of
filters so I can actually just say what
happens if my CSS files get blocked so
I'm going to click I can get it to click
here
I'm going to go request my bootstrap
page again hit ctrl f5 voila looks like
that not a huge surprise but we actually
when we bundle of our CSS files and put
them we put them on on our CDN and like
two days after I did that my CDN had a
hiccup and everybody saw this so I
learned how to write fallback code which
I wish I would have known before I'm
happen you can actually write code to
see the CSS didn't get downloaded so
instead of pulling it from the CDN pull
it off my own server instead so I have
that type of code now this is a way for
me to test and what happens if that
request doesn't work that's kind of a
heavy hammer so there's another way to
do this as well I can take individual
files let me clear this to make a
request the other thing I can do is
there's an autoresponder tab so I can
actually drag I can say I don't want to
all CSS to go away I just have a
particular CSS from a CDN or something I
just want to see what happens if it gets
at 404 I can drag that over to the
autoresponder now I can because it's a
proxy every time the client tries to ask
for that file I can now intercept until
it do something else I'm going to enable
rules I'm going to let all unmatch
requests pass through to the server
because I don't want to mock them all I
just want to do this one but if I get
this one I want to see what would happen
if I get a 404 so I'm going to save that
and if I go back and run this you'll see
what we saw before right the carousel is
gone without that stylesheet this is
what happens so I can use this to
troubleshoot like what happens when a
web font is slow so not only can I block
it and come in here and put a delay like
this one of 20 seconds and I can
actually see if bootstrap CSS doesn't
download I have a blank page right
if I move stuff around I might be able
to get my important Styles above that so
that I'm sure if bootstrap is slow at
least I get some basic rendering of my
page I can do that kind of stuff by
using auto responder and targeting
specific requests okay
what if I'm on a slow connection so if
I'm on a slow connection we'll do this
one in dev tools they've added the
ability to do throttling so they can
actually come down here and say I want
to act like I'm on a 2g connection now
I'll go up here and hit ctrl f5 and
we'll see how long that takes to paint
and all the images and stuff if I'm on
2g so it's just a way for me to quickly
simulate I want to see how this page is
going to run on various levels of
connections you can do that just by
setting this throttling here and again I
can set my own custom for what I want
the latency to be and all that kind of
stuff so that's kind of a cool feature
what if I have another user agent so I'm
going to skip that a given time' but you
can spoof out what your user agent is if
you want to so you can go either into
Fidler or in dev tools and say I'm not
really chrome I'm really iPhone 6 and
then you can see you know from a client
perspective how is the server going to
react to me telling it that I'm a
different type of browser or device okay
how do things work on a first request so
browsers are caching things the quick
way and fiddler to do this I can
actually just come in here and say clear
cache that will clear II's cache so now
when I go into IE it's going to force it
to do that if you go into developer
tools there's a setting by default that
just says disable cache while dev tools
is open so if I do this request let's go
up here first I'll do it where dev tools
is closed I think since we just went to
that page if I just hit a normal refresh
here should this ask for the bootstrap
and probably nothing else okay if I pull
up dev tools now that if dev tools open
and I have that setting if I do that
same refresh you see it actually
requested all the particulars files so
this is the way be aware
you have dev tools open it's going to
act like it's a clean cash situation the
other way that we'll do this
occasionally is go into like incognito
or in private will also act like you
don't have any browser cache so if you
want to see what happens on a first
visit that's the easiest ways to do that
you can simulate different lat/longs
like I said when I was testing for where
to buy our pizzas I can actually put in
specific lat/longs
you can also change the orientation of
your simulated device some dev tools
here if you look at this device toolbar
if I click that here's where I can
choose they do some basic emulation so
they know like what what would this
basically look like on an iPhone or an
iPad just to give you a feeling or you
can set it to responsive and change it
but I can also come down here and say I
want to do more tools sensors and I can
actually put in a lat/long or I can
actually play with the orientation so I
can actually grab that device and act
like I'm turning it anyway now I don't
write websites that are changing by you
know I might do like side to side so I
can do orientation like that I don't do
stuff that's spinning on accesses and
such but if you need to do that that's a
cool feature that's in here or like said
if you need to spoof out a different
lat/long just to see what it looks like
when you're coming from somewhere else
you could do that as well some
miscellaneous things so I talked about
fiddler for now is its stable release
runs on Windows ok so I can run it on my
development machine but I have to
troubleshoot all sorts of devices
iPhones you know any tablets anything
like that that I want to do how would I
do that so the way that I can do that is
I set it up on the same Wi-Fi network so
what I do is I typically end up doing it
at home our security doesn't let me do
this at work so I get on the same Wi-Fi
network with my laptop and whatever
device I want to trace I go onto my
laptop that's where I'm going to run
fiddler I go under tools connections and
you see this allow remote computers to
connect
so that's going to let connections come
into my machine I'm not going to talk
about firewalls and stuff you may or may
not also have to let your firewall let
these connections come through but this
is saying I'm running on this machine on
port 80 8 8 8 the next thing I'll do is
I'll go run IP config on my laptop and
figure out the IP address of this
machine ok once I have that info now I
can go on my phone so I'm going to show
you an example it's not fun setting up
an example with some on the fly for this
sighted one ahead of time on the iPhone
you actually go into your wireless
settings ok and it's going to be
different for all your devices but if
you go into your wireless settings you
scroll to the very bottom there's a
proxy setting you just set the server to
be the IP address of your laptop and
port 8 8 8 8
now all the traffic that you're doing on
that device is now being routed through
fiddler so I can do all that tracing ok
this works for anything if I have to
help somebody at work on another desktop
I can route it to my machine through
fiddler if I want to do that so now I
can troubleshoot I've got a trace just
to show you here's my iphone trace that
I did and if we look at the request see
if I can find it here let me clear that
out we'll do that again I'll show you
that all of the iPhone specific user
agent stuff right there the iPhone so
again this is a way for me to trace so
regardless of the device and the fact
that I can or can't run fiddler on it as
long as I can set a proxy for it and
route it through a machine running
fiddler like that I'm able to get that
trace talk about back-end api's a lot of
people expect so I've got a page here
that calls a web service and I just
gotta pull it up and show you
converts from Fahrenheit to Celsius
I can find it
so 212 Fahrenheit 100 Celsius so when I
did that if I open up fiddler a lot of
people expect that you'll see the call
from the client to the server I really
wanted to capture the web service call
being made by asp.net out to a
third-party service if I come in here I
don't see that and again the reason is
because dotnet called by default within
my code are not set through a proxy like
a browser would I have to specifically
either do this I'll set it and say this
call has to go through this proxy or if
you prefer you can go into web config
and there's a default proxy setting if I
uncomment this all of the calls from any
of the dotnet classes will now get
routed through fiddler so I can trace
all my web api WCF all that stuff that
would normally be from my server-side
code going out to other places I can
trace that in fiddler as well by setting
up the proxy for it but that's why it's
important to understand that fiddler is
a proxy so if you're not seeing it
that's probably why you can also see
HTTP traffic right this should freak you
out little the whole point of HTTP is
that you can't see the traffic where you
can with fiddler because it's a proxy
and you can in chrome dev tools because
it's already decrypted so they come into
here and I go to HTTP I just have to say
decrypt I'm not going to do it here but
the first time I do this fiddler is
going to create its own server
certificate so now when I go on the
client and try to go somewhere fiddler
is going to intercept and give me its
server certificates on the client I'm
going to see a warning that says this is
not Bank on you're going to its do not
trust fiddler you want to trust this
certificate I do right I'm intentionally
trying to do a trace I'll add it to my
browser safe certificate store then for
the rest of time every time I'm
debugging I'll be able to see the HTTPS
so if I go out here and go out to a
let's go out to Google they're using
HTTPS if I go down to their request
which is right here you can see it uses
HTTPS but if I look on the right and
look at the raw I can actually see all
the HTML so if you need to troubleshoot
HTTPS this is a good way to be able to
have fiddler sit and be
and basically decrypt it all for you
okay and again it shouldn't freak you
out too much from security because you
knew it was a bad certificate you choose
to trust it it's only on my own machine
so but it lets me see all that traffic I
get a lot of calls from people that say
your sites not working on my computer
like even senior vice presidents I don't
want to install Fiddler on a senior vice
president machine I'm going to get
blamed when she can't print three years
from now it's my fault so I'm not going
to do that so by default I'm going to
use chrome dev tools first because I can
actually do Network trace and if I do a
network trace let's just do by hit f12 I
go to the network this is my best case
scenario I can do all my tracing and
then come on I can actually right click
here and say save as har it'll save a
har file with all of the same requests
that I can go import then into fiddler
and it's got like 95% of the stuff that
should be there it'll look like I
captured it in fiddler even though I
didn't and I didn't have to install
anything on their machine which is good
the other choice would be if I'm near
them I can actually just go configure
their proxy to point at my laptop at my
desk just like I was with the iPhone
device and I can route it all through my
normal laptop through fiddler that makes
me happy there's also a tool called
fiddler cap I actually had to send this
to a senior VP that was remote that
didn't have Chrome she installed this
all she has to do is hit start capture
go do whatever she wants to do when
she's done she can hit the I'm done with
the capture please save it she gives it
a name she emails it to me and then i
open it up in fiddler and i do all the
troubleshooting that i need to do and it
makes things like please make sure your
cache is cleared and your cookies are
cleared all those things are easy for
her to do okay but I didn't have to you
know I did have to install something
which is unfortunate but at least it's
something that's easy for a
non-technical person to use we'll talk
about some non optimized images if I got
a second here so another tool in fiddler
is
show image bloat so this is a
third-party thing that you can get off
the fiddler site I'm going to
reestablish my proxy so if I go run this
against the conference site again turns
out that pngs have a lot of metadata in
them that describe you know things about
the image that the user doesn't actually
see but if you look this thing adds
bricks to show you how much of the image
is actually metadata so most of this
image is actually metadata that comes
from Adobe Photoshop and stuff I can
actually just go into fiddler pick any
one of them go to image view right click
and say please PNG distill this and it's
going to run it and it's going to cut it
from eight hundred and forty K or some
third bytes or whatever the hell that is
to something smaller okay then I can
actually save that off and take all that
metadata out so we do this on with JPEG
there's a tool called jpg Tran with
strips metadata but if you have metadata
in your PNG s it's a quick way for you
to get a visual of which images have way
too much metadata go strip that metadata
out and they'll be substantial like
eighty-five percent of that one is
metadata we don't want to send that to a
client it doesn't help them saving and
sharing traces I talked about how to do
with a har file you can also do that
with fiddler so I go back and run this
again whatever I have in my trace I can
just say save all sessions give it a
name
I can also password protect it so if I
send the third party people I don't want
people to see all of our network details
and IP addresses and such I can just say
password protected type in a password
I can then email it to them and they can
use it and we actually have a lot of
third-party vendors that understand
fiddler these days so they can actually
help us troubleshoot problems with their
stuff I didn't have time to show you
filmstrip but if you go on the network
tab of Chrome developer tools it shows
you how fast your page is painting and
how soon you can see things so that's
useful in the network part some quick
resources I do have a fiddler course on
Pluralsight course on
Jinjin that Eric had written a very good
book on fiddler probably read it like 10
times every time I read it I find some
more stuff so that's available and then
you can look at the docs for Deb tools
and if you have any questions that's my
email Twitter and blog information and
I'll stick around for a little bit and
when next speaker comes we can take it
aside if you have any particular
questions but that's all I had I'd
appreciate it as you walk out there's a
feedback bin if you'd put in your
feedback Green is good okay so all right
thank you
[Applause]